President Trump will sign a new
executive order this morning targeting
rules that separate religion and
politics the uterus also says religious
groups should not have to pay for birth
control in their employees health
insurance the American Civil Liberties
Union says it will challenge the order
in court the president will also attend
a National Day of Prayer event before
traveling to New York City major good
morning good morning the president's
order will attempt to roll back to
Johnson amendment named after Lyndon
Johnson predates his presidency actually
it's a 63 year old provision of the tax
code that prohibits churches and other
tax-exempt organizations from endorsing
and contributing to political candidates
we have a pro-life president last night
the vice president applauded president
Trump's pro-life advocacy in advance of
his 34th executive order which will
attempt to scale back an Obama
administration edict that religious
organizations provide contraception
services to their employees I will get
rid of and totally destroy the Johnson
amendment the order also seeks to relax
rules prohibiting tax exempt churches
and religious organizations from
engaging in politics one item not in mr.
Trump's order reported draft language
that would have erased another Obama
legacy item by permitting federal
contractors to discriminate against LGBT
employees rolling back his predecessors
achievements is one thing we want to
create peace achieving Middle East peace
is another the president told
Palestinian President Mahmoud Abbas at
the White House that he like his
predecessors would help start peace
talks with Israel three previous
presidents have made the same pledge and
fallen short we will get this done mr.
Trump offered no details but said peace
is not as hard as it looks
say something that I think is frankly
maybe not as difficult
people thought the president staunchly
backs Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and has said little about
Israel's expansion of settlements mr.
Trump however specifically criticized
Palestinian violence against Israel
there could be no lasting peace unless
the Palestinian leaders speak in a
unified voice Middle East peace is a
long-term project for this White House
of much more immediate concern North
Korea and Gayle Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson said yesterday the
administration is putting together a new
round of sanctions against North Korea
for its pursuit of nuclear weapons and
ballistic missile technology all right
Thank You major